fighter in the kid Army what is up we
got Tom Sora on the show today Brian Ken
coming in hot hot from the set yeah you
guys if you're listening this go right
now get your tickets for the live
fireing the kid shows Pacific Northwest
tour Vancouver we added a date so we're
the 18th the 19th is sold out 20th we're
in Portland and then 21st Seattle we got
Seattle all the shows are almost sold
out and then for February we'll be
announcing date soon we are in San
Francisco two nights at the cob we're
Pacific Northwest Darlings what's up
Pacific Northwest tk.com for all those
tickets they're going fast we're not
adding any more shows so Vancouver
Portland Seattle Europe mhm you're
[__] him you're [__]
him you [__] uh dude that's a nice
whip you got Jesus brother what year is
that it's 2013 you call it a whip yeah
dude he dude you guys are know dude we
played ball shut up we what the [__] you
guys are amazing I know I don't know if
you've seen Brian's social media lately
yeah well you know cuz my phone died my
phone died when I I went and looked I
didn't even mean to post that tweet you
know what but I'm I'm going back just
looking at it you keep you're you're
doing that with all your stuff what do
you mean so so when you you're posting
and it's just going I talk about jaguars
and then it's a it's a link to Facebook
on on your I don't then that then that's
a [__] my phone no no what you're doing
is you're you're doing on Instagram
you're hitting Twitter Facebook
everything so it's posting all that so
just hit Facebook that's what I just did
and somehow went to face what are you 70
what is wrong with you dude it's a it's
infuriating kind of question just hit
Facebook that's it no because I I I when
I do the Instagram I go to Facebook
right I I push the button Facebook I
don't hit Twitter and then I do Twitter
separately that's what you should be
doing yeah that's what you're not doing
no you're hitting Twitter for sure I
didn't mean to do that this morning
these buttons but but I was I was Wonder
I'm like like what's wrong with you know
cuz we're talking about social media but
I went back and looked through you've
been doing it for all your [__] maybe
that's my [__] phone cuz I've been
purposely I'm telling you I know exactly
what you're saying what phone do you
have well maybe my phone I know but you
have like cricet or something oh no
that's a new iPhone let's record you
weren't recording that that was great oh
we were record was the best moment of
the day it is recording sorry guys that
that was us candid that was us candid
tomora off the cup skinny Tom as I like
to one of the thinnest Comics working
today you sure are and you guys are just
talking uh when you said to brenon you
go that's a nice whip yeah and I was
like huh and then Brena goes thanks man
and you go when'd you get that and then
Brena goes yeah I was like what are they
talking about Whip and I literally was
like I looked at your body to see if you
had something on you and then you were
talking you were talking about cars you
were like how do I post on Facebook hey
don't make fun of me dude I'm this is my
I'm serious Sensi would you say you're
out of touch with the current situation
with the world that's [__] I read I
read about the alt-right I know what
cuck
means you're a trump cuck a trump cuck
yeah which means you're a race trador
apparently and you're also like a a fake
conservative yeah
yeah for you must have your own world
because we post fan questions you know
yeah and I was going I was just looking
at them and everyone's everything's
mommy jeans oh water board champ or
water Chu champ like I don't understand
it can you explain any of this it's the
I didn't even know how to we you know we
chin and I go through the fan question
like I I mean I don't know what this
means I used to can ask it's endless
inside jokes but there's so many people
you know tapping into it that it's like
its own lexicon it's its own world
you're right I hear and I think they get
a thrill they get a kick out of people
who listen to the show or to your mom's
house they get a kick out of somebody
knowing it but I think they get a bigger
kick out of some being like what they're
like what are you [__] losing you
don't know what the water champ is so
they just it's just it's just nonsense
but it's just jokes everybody but people
want to be tribal everybody wants to be
part of like their own tribe it's so
important it's our language guys
especially like their own language right
but the the jeans comes from what
where's the mommy jeans it's it's okay
it starts off with years ago I think as
a joke my wife and I you know if I was
leaving the house I'd be like I'm gonna
I'm going out I I'll see you later bye
mommy like that like as a silly thing to
say and then it became that there's mom
jeans right so like Mommy jeans so then
we started calling each other we dropped
mommy started calling other jeans and
then see you jeans by jeans yeah and
then your wife yeah to my wife amazing
and then it was like uh oh if you listen
to our show you know like shows have
like you guys you know F than the kid
you have your own maybe like Little tag
we would say cuz you know when you see
guys walking through the airport like
dads like [__] dad like official dads
like in their khakis and they'll wear
their pants high and tight yeah with
those sensible shoes right absolutely
sensible shoes and hats phone holster
they we would say we would spin it to
like that guy knows what's going on
that's a cool guy so we would say like
if you listen to our show you wear your
jeans high and tight like a cool [__]
guy would so then everybody's like you
know if you don't like our show or if
you're like I don't listen to your mom's
house they'd be like oh so you wear them
low and loose like so it just silly
jokes you know but damn it we need we
need some of that vernacular will we
steal it will we have our own I
know Ste [__] what's your what's
some what's some fighter in the kid
vernacular put me on put me on game uh
like uh you like to [__] and and if you
don't like if you don't like to [__]
then [__] you you know what I'm saying
so that's code yeah and then also and
also like we like to crush on stage and
come we Crush man I think those picked
up no I'm just saying you and I and then
then we then we go hey man you want to
you want to open up the whips and I mean
like we're you never heard the term
whips before this 20 years old it's 20y
old SL seriously I mean it's like a whip
a car [__] how the [__] that have that
I'm I'm I'm H have you seen the arrival
yet no I hear it's good it's really good
Jennifer Lawrence she's not in it yeah
not oh sorry what is she in she's in
some other [__] Space movie oh God I
can't keep up Ral I he is really good
yeah the aliens like do you like big
dicks and then that girl is like what
what yeah it's crazy that's crazy and
then so it's a movie about [__] yeah
so these aliens don't know how to
communicate that they have big dicks
right like well they ask and then she
leaves and she tells the army guys like
they all have big and they make her go
back sounds like a terrible movie it's
really cleverly told I'm kind of
simplifying it right it's really good
I'm totally simpli [__] like you like it
well that's again if you're if you're
not into our podcast then you don't you
don't like the [__] how are the live cuz
I see you guys posting the live show I
don't know is it good that we sold out
Vancouver in less than a week I don't
know and we had to open up to another
show so we got to fill up where you
going basically ah theater twice doesn't
matter who Seattle Portland that's
[__] awesome in San Francisco cobs in
February you guys are killing it
breaking news what's the live show like
do you guys do live shows we do it's but
I mean you know we've done them we've
done live shows for years we usually we
haven't traveled that much with them but
now you know the my son just turned one
it's tough so it's definitely harder to
yeah we're the couple yeah so it'd be
like Brian and I were gay and had a kid
we thought we're basically married
though yeah kind of like I don't have to
deal with you all day no you take care
of his kids no no no he he's not very
father I take a me I'm not fatherly no I
mean I mean with other kids excuse me
sir no you're very fatherly but great
dad Beast of a dad he
uh take but um with you you guys you do
like a straight podcast like you're not
doing a show right like you you guys all
right no it be it would be the Pod would
we would do our our podcast but we have
a lot of produced like it's a show show
you segments in it yeah we have audio
like a lot of audio stuff that you know
audio clips so it's it's that's part of
how our show works so when it's live
that plays but we end up playing you
can't help it if you you know your
Comics you have crowds like you end up
playing the Crow so it sort of ends up
being well not sort of it ends up being
a more joke heavy you married a really
funny woman yeah and Bren and I have
talked about this let's just be honest
for a sec yeah very funny women are a
rare commodity do you have a theory on
why that is um I don't know man Pete
Holmes was on the podcast saying that
you know women men comedy's hard for
women basically because men won't give
them a chance and no he was saying women
got a late start but they're just as
good as guys but they got a late start
and I slapped them in this isn't my
theory I think this is actually and then
shoved a handful of [__] spinach down
his face did you and meat and meat no no
meat Thomas he's a vegan um I my I think
she told me this Theory I think it's
pretty good is that one of the things
about like funny behavior is that it's
really encouraged in boys you know like
joking around like they're being boys
and that a lot of times with like little
girls people are like hey hey you know
knock that off like if if you're being
crass if you're being silly they're like
be proper be more you know be more
ladylike and it's almost like it's
you're corrected to be a certain way
there's a lot of funny girls though I
wouldn't say that there's you know women
women are my my sister I watch my sister
and stuff if they're raised a certain
way yeah they'll be a lot like guys in
the way they interact with each other
like I noticed they're not as
sentimental right I don't know I don't
know then again I don't know if that's a
good argument they're not it's a
terrible argument sentimental meaning
um meaning is G giving each other as
much space for their emotions so a lot
of times you'll see it seems that women
tend to be more uh charitable in how
they allow their friends to express
themselves emotionally right so they can
cry and they're there for each other if
you and I start crying it better be a
really good reason right I disagree I I
think I disagree I mean obviously I
think women are more open to it I think
the guys who are shut off emotionally
it's not good man I'm not saying it's
good or not I'm saying that's how men
are what I'm saying is that guys are not
very apt to show their emotions around
each other the way women are you think
that contributes to being funny then I I
I I think that I don't know man I I
don't have a theory on this but I do
think that women interact differently
with each other true than men do so men
men humorous insult with men like we we
[__] with each other all the time right
true and and even even if you like even
if you say like if I make fun of you and
you get offended you and I would be like
well I don't know if you can be my
friend dude if you're that sensitive
right that's true you know what I'm
saying where women are way more precious
about that but isn't that an extension
of what I was talking about that it's
like encouraged Behavior yeah they're
not encouraged to engage in that b i
remember then I ask why like why though
you know what I mean is biolog not
ladylike right like if a girl if a
female comes in starts busting your
chops you're like Jesus Christ that's
not attractive but watch you'll see this
when your kids when your when your kids
are older
you'll see with your typically what
happens is your kid will have an
emotional reaction right and men and
they've done a lot of studies on this
men tend to kind of go you know you'll
be all right but and and you try to
treat it with humor or you try to like
dissipate the emotion you try to go uh
it's not that big a deal your instinct
is to go hey it's going to be all right
relax and then you make a joke and you
get on a laugh what women tend to do
from my experience but also from what
I've read about because I had to read
about this is that is that they will
they will listen
they will actually absorb the emotion
they'll feel it with their kid and
they'll acknowledge the emotion so what
children will do is when they're really
hurt or when they're you know feeling
they'll go to their mommy they won't go
to their dad right you know and and um
and apparently both sides are needed you
need humor to dissipate but but women
tend to absorb that that makes a lot of
sense but it's but it's also not yeah I
think to Tom's point it's not encouraged
for women to get into comedy yeah I mean
there's also I think there's a slow
crawl you can tell that it's definitely
you know there's more audiences
accepting and and into funny oh our
society wants a female to play
quarterback Dallas Cowboys yeah but it
is slower right like there's still like
there's there's still an audiences guys
I'm saying even men and women who go
like I don't want to see a a woman on
stage being funny that that still exists
but I think it I think it's trending
towards the other way well some women
like your your wife and like Eliza
cesinger and some women are are just
funny man yeah you know they're
undeniable if you're undeniable one time
I was I was at a club where she was on
stage and I was bath yeah my wife's on
stage and uh these two guys go in the
bathroom and one guy goes there's a
chick on stage and uh and the other guy
goes what are her tits look like and
he's like pretty good and he's like I
guess I'll take a listen and that was
and I was like Christ some dude [__] me
dude we were but I think a lot of times
too like I obviously women come to
comedy shows and I think a woman might
rather watch another lady right like
they can relate to them more cuz if I'm
up there talking about whatever
something dude thing hunting killing
most women they can't relate to it right
I I I guess it depends on your comedy I
mean look we say we say this there
someone would uh argue with us on every
point about this what about because you
can't just make anything a blanket
statement but the reality is most people
are drawn to something relatable or
like-minded in other words you know the
people that love and follow Chris Rock
or Chelsea Handler or you know any
completely different they go they go I
want I agree to some you know I like
this line of thinking I'm going to
somebody who is
in just I relate to it they absolutely
if you're talking about [__] that like
they have no clue about chances are
you're not going to be like that's my
favorite comic I don't know what the
[__] he's talking about
then again Richard PRI talked about a
world a lot of people didn't live and he
had a huge white follow so it depends on
sometimes great comedy great comedy can
just transcend all of it like you're
just like this motherfucker's hilarious
and he's doing characters that I've
never really met right but God I I I bet
they yeah he can do anything kind he's
an outlier that's kind of where art
transcends all of it like when when
somebody does something so original that
all everybody's like [__] man yeah I
heard that thing one time that said that
you know everything is preference rise
is supposed to be subjective right I
like this you like that blah blah blah
but that greatness actually isn't
subjective greatness is objective
meaning that correct you don't go even a
fool can
appreciate so you know I don't know I
think Eddie Murphy was you know for me
for my age I think your your age kind of
spes you up I'm 37 so like prior even
though I I know his greatness it just
wasn't something that I was watching you
know he was I was just I was born just a
little too late for it so Murphy he was
incredible dud I saw Delirious not too
long ago and it's still super [__]
still holds up yeah super raw and
Delirious especially Delirious man I
remember 1983 dude I remember listening
to
Delirious years old listen to how he
does like his Impressions I remember
listening and when I listen to him like
I he was so mindboggling it was the
first guy cuz I'd heard Carlin and all
those guys but you're right Eddie Murphy
was the first guy that was mindboggling
was
we're all we we at least I you know we
focus so much on what is like the um
Insight of the comedian you know like
what is it's funny but he's telling this
truth and he was just funny it wasn't
that like oh my God what a what the
hypocrisy that he's revealing he was
just straight up funny straight up funny
where it wasn't it didn't matter if you
were Harvard educated or a high school
dropout you found him equally funny you
know whereas now I mean not that either
thing is bad but I feel like there is an
emphasis on the intelligence behind the
bit that annoys me personally annoys me
too it annoys but you also can't help
sometimes it's in your head like oh is
this insightful enough is this you know
you think because the crowds are smarter
I think it's no I think it's our paying
attention too much to people like blogs
and Expo people talking about the
intellect involved with it when you
really should just be you know worried
about the the show the perform well also
you know the idea that a comic is going
to really get you to think in a
different way is a bit of a stretch
because you know it it's people love
simple answers and they love simple
imagery yeah and so if you're a really
great comic you'll get people to go I
never thought of it that way but it
doesn't mean it's true like you can be a
sist and make fun of things obviously
most issues are way more complicated and
layered but it good Comics can get you
to go you know what what if the world
really was like that but obviously it's
more complicated I think when people
come to a comedy show maybe they want to
escape from all that stuff I'm not
trying to hear your opinions on Trump
right now man correct no I or the the
state of you know racism and stuff like
that like God damn I get it everywhere
man come here
bye more about that the week of the
election I I was in Louisville and I it
was two days later and Louisville is a
blue City in a red State mm so it's like
one of those meaning it's a democratic
City yeah for the [__] dummies that
don't know that um
so I did know so I'm sitting there and I
I I bring it up at first and there's
actually like people were like I think
there their thing was like which way are
you going on this cuz I just brought it
up be careful and then I could sense
relief when I just moved on I mean after
like a minute yeah they were just like
we're exhausted of this can we move on
and it was like gladly and then just
went on my my dad called me when uh I
think it was the first time I was going
up at the Laugh Factory he goes you know
I think you should do a Donald Trump bit
he's so hot right now I'm like thank you
Dad thank you well I've I appreciate it
I've been doing no one else is doing
that and that's definitely my Lane yeah
I appreciate it I'll tell a joke on
[__] mechanical engineering next yeah
yeah I've I've been talking about race
God and um I met your dad by the way no
yes I did no you didn't yes I did where
uh in Toronto did you really yeah your
fight really yes dope yeah I met him
with it was weird because your parents
came to the show the night before yes
that's right and then I met them with
Ken and they complimented him so much I
was like did you see the show like uh
and did you see me I don't like that
point of VI and they were like you're
the best to him and no they didn't I
don't remember saying that they never
saw the show
they
you were you did you just get off the
road with Rogan when recent am I going
crazy no I haven't gone with him in a
while God I thought you did Tom sells
out theaters right now no I know that
but I saw him show off shut up maybe it
was here or was it is it a New Year's no
I haven't I did a podcast with him but I
haven't I haven't done shows you haven't
you haven't done a show with him
probably in two years right well I'm
sure no I'm sure I've done a show with
him in two but it's been a while it's
been a while we did uh we did the we did
the store the same night last week yeah
that's it in fct yeah once your Netflix
special came out and people saw how
funny you were it was game over it
helped it helped a lot for sure and I
heard Netflix is changing the game a
little bit because now they're
they're people's attention span for
those hours unless you're in Eddie
Murphy Chris Rock Dave Chappelle uh
those guys that they're what they're
noticing is the hours are simply too
long for someone to sit down watch a
whole kind of special yeah so now
they're gearing towards half an hour
yeah that's true that that makes a lot
of sense even me when I watch TR to
watch a bunch of one hours and I was
like after about half hours well they
know the data too they don't share it
but they know when you press pause they
know so they know that people are saying
they're not making that [__] up no they
they know and then what they're doing is
obviously it's pretty clear it's out in
the media too they they have these huge
budgets you know they paid Chris Rock
Dave Chappelle you know how much money
so then they want to make it like
exclusive to be on Netflix they don't
want it like you know it's not knocking
Comedy Central or what Showtime but
there's a ton of people on there they
want Netflix very Where damn you got a
special on Netflix and that's what
they're doing so they're saving the big
dollars for those Comics yeah yeah it's
an interesting play and they like you
said they know the numbers but they
don't they don't they don't release it
ever my feelings get hurt when they
don't even tell you when you're when
you're on there like I asked Rogan like
his came out and then a week later I'm
like dude how are we doing he's like I
have no idea yeah I have no idea they
don't the most I ever got was you never
find out happy they don't tell you you
you'll know if they want you to do
another one they yeah that you they're
all business yeah like ah come back yeah
that means performed well yeah but
that's basically it and it's weird right
cuz you think and by the way they they
have like serious non-disclosures you
know if you're an employee really so you
can't pull that info like I've been like
come on man I talk [__] I talk [__] to
Netflix guy at one of our live shows in
Minnesota because Brian was trying to
get a special on there they didn't pick
it up and we do fan questions at the end
of live shows and he rais hand he goes
don't kill me I work for Netflix I went
hold up man and then roasted him for
about 10 minutes yeah I was like hey bro
sign the contract right now put him on
there he's like I'll talk to my guy we
never heard from a lot of it just has to
do with how popular you are to begin
with and even though CU I happen to know
that the people that make the decision
saw me kill a room they saw you know and
they saw my one of my best sets think
the model changed though yeah they were
like it's all about timing like if you
if they had seen that set two years ago
you're on that's right I think now
they're doing like they might do
somebody who's been on before kind of
your grandfathered in again but they
really want to go for the name names for
the hour has following it's yeah it's
not I don't think it's a knock on anyone
or anything like that that half hour
thing's a good idea it's kind of fair I
thought it was a great idea I but it's
weird to me that they won't give you
your numbers cuz you're like no but then
talking you know what I was talking to
somebody about like because they don't
want you to have uh leveraging Power
about they want you to negotiate right
so if you knew you crushed it you'd be
able to come back and say I want even
more money but that but that's that's
terrible business on were you North
Korea I know hey man how did I do you
killed it we're just going to give you
the same deal and it's weird because
it's a publicly traded company you know
they're basically like take it or leave
it man you're like of course Chappelle
got 60 jillion dollars you gave me 40 I
just feel like I need to negotiate take
it or leave it because you know at the
end of the day the funny thing is even
though those guys are making
astronomical money it's not about the
money you'd make that much on that it's
still I mean even though you want that
money it's still about cuz you know that
platform is so big yes that if 100
million people can watch you on there
you're like I'll take it I know man no
matter what I just want to be able to
sell a lot of tickets on the road that's
you're doing it not as much as I'd like
to though but it's getting better and
better you got to get better social
media yeah really social media
sucks Brian's yeah 50 50 he's 50 50 out
of 100 no no his age yeah I call him a
dinosaur no because how old are you but
I look 32 whoa 33 what' you think I was
I didn't know him I just didn't 40
something no I thought right got thick I
need a nap in a water yeah no you're all
right he just got thick skin on your
face from getting punched in sports How
would how would he do in a fight not
good no
well not good what against who yeah
that's a big he I don't like don't
answer so quickly bro ask me against who
like a
scrappy
30 6 s year
old wait a minute you know hey dude you
calling me out you want to step not
saying me but let's say like a guy like
you feeling froggy leap who's uh feeling
froggy obviously strong like what how
how would he do hell of a beard I feel
like pretty good cuz I feel like that
guy you're talking about even if he had
a really cool leather Jack from All
Saints I feel like you'd throw one hell
of a right hand that cross is [__]
just mean so what happens when I step
back because I can measure your shots
cuz I do it all the time and then bang
Bang Yeah you know what I'm saying is
that what it is bang bang bang bang dude
I don't know what it is but at boxing
bur I I trained the earlier in the
morning before I come here it's like
actors freaking row there now there's
just tons of actors now like tons of
them wait are you doing are they doing
one-on-one or like they're doing one-on
ones but there was two guys um who you
know them if I told you forget their
names but they train together and
there's Toby McGuire and then there's
freaking uh homeboy uh then Frank
grillo's up there I'm looking around
like since when did all this happen
Frank Grill is probably the only actor
that can actually box right no as far as
like fight what about Mickey Ro no no
it's like some some of those actors I
don't know how long they've been doing
it but are good yeah man like I I stood
and watched him I was chatting with him
like [__] these guys are actually pretty
good and then uh Chris uh Hemsworth yeah
he was in there that dude's in shape
though man that probably beat he'd
probably beat everyone up in the room is
right my God he's a monster he's in uh
what is he's like Thor or some [__]
right is Thor he's a big
biging that motherfucker's not I mean
he's tall he's slender in shape like a
[__] he box like [__] so he
would [__] Callen up oh my God Thor we
haven't seen I'd have my hand full yeah
but you know you haven't seen the way I
I catch angles no I haven't seen it and
you haven't seen what happens when I get
hit and I have to dig down deep cuz I
when I dig down deep yeah you none of
you guys in this [__] room has seen
what happened when I want to dig down
deep and what I do is I take both my
hands yeah I I make Palms I put my face
in my hands and I go and I go nope I
don't I go say nope iar which means God
is great don't
say all right I don't even say that
that's some different [__] not not I'm
not a Muslim not a Muslim what I do is I
take my hands like this you're right to
think that I would be praying that way I
put my face in my hands and I and they
ignite a
you inside my chest I go I go you can be
somebody someday you can be somebody you
better you better Tom you're better than
Brennan I just say that cuz you guys are
there watching ridiculing me and then I
pull my hands away and you punch
yourself in the face and and I run at
him yeah I run at him with my face you
run out of the gym I do want to see you
fight I look at him I go I look at him I
go you're going to have to kill me
you're going to have to kill me and then
it's just body you die the body watch
you
die and then can we you fight for
charity why don't you do a charity I die
as I die I flip both you off and I just
di did you guys ever do a charity thing
like that would you ever if someone came
to you and was like Tom Brian listen not
against each other but yeah you know may
maybe you and Bert I mean look I would
scope out I think it's uh if it's for
charity I think like anybody right you
look at what what is the actual scenario
what are we looking at here um let's say
I put on charity fight night which I
could easily do blow it out and I have
you and Bert as the main event my God
that would do and all the charity goes
to this this uh kids home that I don't
want to herur BD I was about to say that
my biggest issue when like my my trainer
wants me to fight Freddy Prince Jr for a
charity I like how you guys think you're
GNA hurt him like you guys are dangerous
well yeah I will hurt you if I punch you
in the face not really I mean if if this
excuse me if I punch you in the face I'm
going to hurt you if Freddy boxes way
more than you do sir no you're wrong I
box as much as he does
that's not true you're on the road all
the time I box as much as Freddy does
that's not true hey hey we belong to the
same gym I know what I'm talking about I
just talked to Freddy yesterday he hey I
know what I'm talking about so can you
just can I talk can I talk for a second
go talk how tough you are can I talk no
what I'm saying is that it's not what I
was going to say if You' let me finish
what I'm saying is that he wants me to
do a boxing charity with Freddy right I
like Freddy Freddy's great guy the
problem with fight with doing that yeah
is that I if it's a charity and people
are watching I'm really going to [__]
box yeah and I find it very awkward when
I Spar to even hit somebody hard with a
jab because it's awkward and you're
hurting them so when I get in there and
I jab somebody man why don't we and so
all of a sudden what I do hey dude you
got in the ring with me and I gave you a
headache and if the guy's pretty good I
don't want to get hit I'm going to be
trying to hit you back but you guys but
it's for charity and you guys are going
to have headgear on 60 hurts dude it's
for a charity and also I mean doing it
at whatever what gym do you go to glove
works you guys would raise 14
so but if you did it at the right venue
and the right charity not you're
completely missing my point no no I get
what you're saying I'm telling you if
you guys did it once trust me both you
would be just fine you're not going to
knock him out Berard Hopkins I don't
know all all I do know Brandon is that I
know this I know you think I'm a
complete [__] all I'm saying I'm not
saying you I'm telling you Freddy would
be fine well well or he wouldn't or I
wouldn't somebody's going to somebody
I've gotten hit in the head not even
that like hard by a female boxer it
[__] really hurts
I'm trying to say is that you're not
going to go balls to the wall and try
ripping Freddy's head off otherwise
you're probably not the guy for the gig
right what I'm saying is that when
people get Andy Dick in there but then
as a but when you're sparring and a lot
of people are watching I always feel
like it's going to escalate like I
always feel like you're going to get hit
I I guess what I'm saying is that I
would find it very awkward I really
wrestling Jiu-Jitsu something different
you brother then you would never do it
but you could get guys like Tom and Bert
together you could get there's a ton of
could do I think it'd be more fun for me
to not do it with Bert though so
honestly cuz you're so close yeah and
it's like um let's say let's say just
body shots let's say you're right you're
right you could but I'm saying let's say
you're like look I want to be able to
just punch I don't really want to I'm
not saying that I you know I would
devastate him but like I don't really
want to rock that dude you know what I
mean like I don't want like to rock my
I'm with I I don't want to happen either
however it's charity you guys to have
head gear on 16 o gloves it still hurts
brenon you're Pro fighter so for me
[__] hurts I don't know maybe I'm
I've seen so many smokers I've seen
these Charities before no everyone
walked away just fun it'd be more fun to
do someone I don't like we could do that
yeah who do you not like let's go down
the list so no I you so the way I look
at is if you're if you're even remotely
athletic and you've been and you you
train enough right say you train three
days a week okay and then you shout out
bxs you can get to a point where you can
actually throw a right hand pretty hard
right and it's not hard to hurt
somebody's head yeah and I I you know
I'm telling you here's the other thing
you forget that like the less trained
you are so let's say he and I are in the
ring the less control you have over oh
I'm going to do it this way and make
sure not to do that your instincts are
going to be like which means the more
exhaust you're going to get totally so
after a minute everyone's going to be
just fine I'm telling you I've seen
these million times but you guys no
one's conditioned enough you're right
we're and the other thing is is you
could do uh just your left hands so get
we Tie Your Right hands behind your back
that's funny but then hurt then it's
even then it's crazier and yeah yeah for
charity depends on the charity you know
what I'm saying I have you be mascot you
could be in Mascot [__] like he could be
in a seminal outfit where'd you go to
school Lenor Ry who's the mascot Bears
dude boom you come out as a big bear
he's a seminal I'm in I'm in Lululemon I
want to wear white I want to wear tight
tight sick yeah you got nice ass I'm a
tank top I'm oiled up shaved it was for
the right charity it'd be fun I feel
like no matter what I'd throw a [__]
left hook and then he'd be like I do
stand up through a straw
now and I just feel you're responsible
for him yeah well well there's to the to
Brian's Point GC and Jason Ellis decided
to fight Shane Carwin Shane Carwin had
one hand and you called it I remember
Brennan like quietly was saying this
well I'm worried about Jason because
Shane was going to hit him and and I go
yeah but he's got his left hand tie
behind and he goes hey it doesn't matter
cuz that's a pro yeah and and you see it
how B you called it knocked him out he
knocked him out oh yeah didn't he knock
him down the first time he knocked him
down I think in the second round he
knocked him out cold he knocked him out
cold yeah but it's like but but and he
had and he only had one Ellis had both
hands Ellis is athletic and strong yeah
and he works out a lot and boxes Shane
had Shane had just his left hand just
his left just his left when was this
this was like a few months ago at Ellis
Mania I told Ellis a bad idea but you
know he's one time with one time with
brenon I had you know Ellis I've done a
show yeah he's a great dude with Brendon
one time I have a I have a friend who um
who's a boxer and he's an actor but he
spends a lot of time boxing he's good
and I said how would you do against him
like he's he moved so well and he goes
and he looked at me he goes you're
hurting my feelings right now yeah and I
go what he goes why are you asking me
this I go because I've seen him move
around he hits hard and he goes Brian I
would I could tie my hand behind my back
and knock him out I remember thinking
that's an obnoxious thing to say and I
didn't believe him I thought it was a
little bit obnoxious and disrespectful
and then I see Shane Carwin do it to a
guy who's even better than the guy I was
talking and bigger people just don't
realize they just don't real like that
was his job for 10 years that's like me
asking you guys hey man I got a buddy uh
he works at Kinkos how would he do on a
special on Netflix just for an hour like
he just got up there he's never done it
it's true yeah yeah yeah I know it's
absurd although czy no no but a little
bit different cuz you when somebody
boxes all the time and they're an
amateur right or not even amateur
they're like an actor or they're a
personality but let's say they box four
days a week and then you watch days and
they hit Ms well well even if they Spar
like once while let's say you so you'll
tell me I sparred right that's not like
it's Spar
for a Hollywood actor yes yeah it's not
yes it's not the problem is there's an
illusion because you're a celebrity
paying this in in most of our friends
cas they're paying this world champion
boxer to train them to spar them well if
he just dropped you to the body and gave
you a concussion every time there's no
money in it for him so he's going to he
wants to show Improvement you know he's
going to play the game and even that
when I say I sparred uh there's a guy
who's there who's had 12 Pro fights he's
a Mexican guy small guy he's really
good he was a really big amateur uh
Mexican amateur Pro and he hits me so
lightly and all so it's not really
sparring what he's doing is moving
around and pressing action and so I get
to feel like I'm moving around I get but
by the way I'm missing them most of the
time but for me that's sparring right
for me or if I get in with a guy who's
not that athletic and hasn't had much
boxing it feels really good for me to
think because I've done a little more
that I get to like see when he's coming
because he's not very good I move back I
get to like hit him and not hard and it
makes me feel like if I wanted to that's
a great feeling to be honest and it's
also a great a great workout so so again
that's what I'm saying is that you want
me to get in some people fall this line
like I hear guys I sparred a day six
rounds like I know you paid that boxer
to give you a sweat this is what this
which is a cool which is fine I'm all
for it I did a I did a boxing class in
uh in in Glendale with this for the
former pro Armenian guy right and he's
training the class it's like a group
it's a group class and he's like I'm
tell you about different Fighters okay
and Mexicans they don't stop they don't
stop you hit them you hit them they keep
coming back relx
fast
strong fast strong Russians good
technique he just
label's all them yeah he's pretty good
on all of them he's like perfect punches
perfect punches that's interesting
because you can like tell a lot about a
culture by the the style of boxing yeah
right yeah he was just like mexic are
Relentless what' he say he said Mexicans
are Relentless in their nature but it's
also like that I mean they have to like
if you're going to be a Mexican boxer
you can't be this like flashy no heart
you know type of dude like otherwise the
Mexicans aren't going to follow you yeah
he was saying that um I think he was
saying that like klitsch go yeah he goes
they'll do like their training will be
500 left Jabs MH 500 right cross Basics
like like just over and over and over
and over and over and that that would be
uh simple stuff yeah but like just until
it's you know it's so second nature and
it's so technically sound those brothers
are insane the one is the the senator or
I mean he's he's the he's a politician I
believe they both have their phds in
exercise physiology they both have phds
they phds have phds six six and then
gold medalist winner and then uh yeah
one's a politician now for did you see
that press conference with with the
Tyson uh Conor Tyson Fury yeah yes where
he was like I'm fat yeah he was like
look at me he's like you work your ass
off got this beautiful body he's like
and I beat you I'm the champ gets his
stomach out he goes you can't call me an
athlete he like I'm not that's an insult
to athletes did you hear what happened
to that gentleman though huh uhuh so
Tyson Fury was uh diagnosed uh medically
uh insane can't compete positive for
cocaine they stripped him of the belt so
now it's Klitschko verse uh uh um
Anthony Joshua so that was after that
press conference that that happened so
he yeah so he they so he claimed he
rolled his ankle before they're supposed
to fight so they did all this press he
backed out rolled his ankle blah blah
blah everyone's like that's weird
because they showed him getting hammered
like a week later in Scotland or some
[__] like that and then so the fight's
back on and then he pulled out and
everyone's like what is going on man so
they had him uh sit down with someone
they're like he's not mentally stable to
compete stripped him of the Bel is there
any followup on that story or he's just
been laying low he died he died he's
dead I made that up he dead he's not
doing well got text he's not doing well
though no yeah he's a gypsy and you're
like I don't know it's tough God they're
the worst right sad story have have
there been any English gypsies in the
UFC you train with any of those guys now
I train with them yeah or any anybody
come from that kind of world or are they
mostly boxers I don't know I
know I don't know Tom who's here what
what do you what's well I was I was
congratulating Tom because when he went
on uh Rogan I said dude you talked you
got to talk about sports like straight
up sports for an hour yes we talked a
bit about basketball and football just
about but doesn't watch any of that
stuff I know we were talking about
athleticism so it kind of and then he
you know was into a little bit of the
idea that these guys are freaky athletes
you know NBA players and NFL players but
obviously I can't get into the to the
details of each sport cuz he'll be like
don't care don't watch no room in my
brain for that so he has like you know
but you're a big Sports guy I like yeah
I'm I mean I'm casual sports fan of big
events you know so I'll I'll follow a
World Cup I'll follow us open but like I
I'm more into I'm into college football
a lot kind of NFL second after that for
me NBA after that so you're into college
b ball more than you are into
professional ball too way more I think
and the numbers would show that too that
people are because it's less predictable
I just don't care I just I it's actually
happened with with you know with every
year that goes by I don't give a [__]
about about Dan I don't me NE I mean
like I watch it for some's on I'll watch
it highlights like you know you see
great plays but I don't have an
emotional investment in a team I wonder
why that is cuz I feel the same way and
a lot and their ratings are down too
ratings are down but in college football
they're killing it and if it's like
number two versus number six I'm I'm not
from Clemson I'm not from WatchON I will
watch every emotion is so high maybe the
games are more exciting for in my op the
games are better the crowd well every
game definitely more every game matters
I don't know what it is yeah I mean
there's one thing like I mean look
there's Arguments for both Sid there's
there's no question that the NFL has a
higher caliber player on the field yeah
I mean this they're all Pros right this
is why they're there but I mean you can
are first of all let's say being a
champion in either League you could be
eight and8 in the NFL and run the table
in the playoffs and win the Super Bowl
you could lose eight games and be the
world champion that you know at most in
college you could be a two loss team at
most you lose two and it better be two
good teams that you lost to yeah you
can't lose to some I will say this I
watched my friend made me sit down and
watch Marsh Madness some of the games
I've never watched any of it that is
high drama the [__] is high drama
because the games can go you know one
way or another like all the kid makes a
mistake and then oh yeah well because
they're College show they make mistakes
they mistak NFL not a lot of mistakes
and look even like a regular season game
uh at Duke watching the crowd there
versus an NBA playoff crowd you can't
compare that and also that's night and
day but at at Duke those players are
putting 100% effort in in the NBA if
it's early in the season those guys
aren't really playing it has to do also
that that coaching player Dynamic it
just changes in the in college coaches
can be dictators a coach can be like
you're going to get up at this time
you're going to eat this he's going to
be Authority you're a dictator you can
be like and guess what if you if you say
no if you give me any [__] about any of
this you're not playing you can stay
home all this [__] that like they
they're in control the dynamic shifts in
the pros in the pros the players are the
stars well it's about ego managing
because I don't think Phil I don't think
Phil Jackson was the best Co coach I
think he was the best at dealing with
these personalities and these Egos and
making sure everyone's cohesive and was
a team sure I don't you know his
triangle offense is amazing but that's
not like groundbreaking or how homeboy
who just won with the uh [__] what's
his name uh Lou Ty Lou or whatever the
[__] his name is the the coach for the
Cleveland Cavaliers oh yeah yeah yeah
you think he's the best coach in the NBA
one he's the homie he's just a dude
LeBron's like uh he he would drop a play
in Lebron like let's [__] get that out
of here here listen this what yeah yeah
but he maybe he's good at creating
Harmony right maybe I think he just and
also I think little bit just gets out of
the way like look at Luke Walton with
the Golden State how many games do they
win yeah you think he's the best coach
in the NBA no come on no he's just the
he's like you guys do your thing some of
that though in basketball like
basketball is one of those Sports where
if you have that many studs in your
stable like I could go out there that's
what I'm saying is it the easiest kid in
the world for sure I I'm not saying that
like these guys don't know a [__]
thing but there's no way you can tell me
like hey you get Steph and Durant and
like see if you can pull out a win okay
I'll take my [__] I guarantee you you
are you kidding me they wouldn't skip
too much of a beat if the night before I
went Steph how exactly are you doing
things he like we do this this there and
then when do you when should I call
timeouts well when there's a change in
kind of the you the dynamic and the
energy game like that dude looks tired
okay cool them out time out and then
there not a huge Playbook whereas I feel
like football the playbooks are so thick
you got offensive coordinator defensive
coordinator all this scheming you know
like there's a lot more of jazz in
basketball for sure you know football
like that like if football it's like if
this defense is set up like and and
you're running plays that it's it's
stopping it's going to keep stopping
like you can't just be like well we'll
just kind of you have to make real
adjustments we remember in football it's
also like this defensive coordinator's
game plan versus this offens coordinator
game plan who are balls deep in football
and then they have it's basically like
if you think about it's almost like a
video game cuz they they have these 11
players who they that have to run this
play and there's this guy who's smarter
than everyone on the field telling them
what to run is he up there up there
there's up there's people up there the
in the booth there's guys on the field
but and they get pictures of exactly
what the offense running think about
it's a smart as [__] white or black dude
who's older yeah who they try to get the
best to to run their Concepts yeah and
they also that old guy verus this old
guy it's also about misleading like the
whole thing that they're trying to do is
oh you watch this film of us running
like that when we have two tight ends we
run the ball this guy goes I know that
you watch that film and you think every
time we have two tight ends we run the
ball so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to put two tight ends and I'm
going to pass you know yeah so they're
always and and then they'll but maybe
you expect that I'm going to do that so
they always try to throw things the
problem is you have so many plays in a
game that you've got to do that for so
you realize how intricate that and
there's also this thing that like um
coordinators hold on to the Playbook so
what they do is they'll know they'll
need some magic later in the season so
sometimes they'll withhold running
formations and play college is really
good cuz College what they will do say
Ohio State's playing I don't know [__]
mcne state mcne state or chattan
just throw it deep just it's so basic
where if they're playing Michigan State
the following week they got it's very
vanilla cuz they just have so much
better players it's literally like you
could run whatever play they're going
score a touchdown belly on
one every play straight up because they
can't they're just I never thought of
football as being this old guy over here
versus this old guy 100 that's
fascinating video games it's basic when
you think about it it's kind of like
obviously they know so much about the
game but but it's kind of weird to think
about cuz like this old guy's Concepts
versus this old guy's Concepts and then
they have these the gr but explain to me
then if you have the head coach who's
the ultimate boss right yeah so he he
he's talking to the defensive
coordinator he's probably listening to
him no it depends on the coach but but
sometimes the head coach he obviously
started off there was offense defense
cor what a position coach now he's a
head coach now what they really do they
come up with schemes and obiously who
who makes the team stuff like that but
he's also in charge of saying it's
fourth and one there's three minutes
left in the game we're down by six punt
or uh go for it he's the guy who's going
go for he makes the executive decision
EXA he's the president a lot ofure he's
the president that's a lot ofure
president he's the president that's the
government's they always say that the
president has there's a team yes they
always say the president like one of the
reasons and they advise them you know
because but also typically you have lots
of different points of view right they
go this is best for this play this is
best for this play and and everybody has
their own agenda and a lot of times they
don't like each other so Connor leer
rice never used to speak she wasn't on
speaking terms I think with uh with the
Secretary of Defense Donald Rumsfeld
they hated each other really and yes and
that's very typical in administrations
if you read the history of like the
Secretary of State can't [__] stand a
secretary of defense and they won't talk
and they'll come with their plans and
the president has to make a choice yeah
president's like well and then I it's
not it's not really like Up For Debate
like that defense coordinator it's his
call you know what I'm saying like he's
put in that position there's a lot of
pressure on them offense coordinator too
yeah wow it's a I like also in college
the rivalries are you know they're more
exciting to me like I it's teams I don't
even follow but the Rivalry you know
like LSU Alabama I'm going to watch that
every year I'm going to watch Oklahoma
Texas Michigan Ohio State I mean this
year that was [__] bananas and then
now since I'm in Southern California
obvious I played University of Colorado
and they had a good year so I was even
more Inge football they were to top 10 I
think we ended number 10 we playing ESP
a lot of people don't know like Colorado
used to be the [__] man well you know
last year we had the worst record in the
Pack 12 and this year Pack 12 South
Champions so the coach won AP Coach of
the Year McIntyre well I heard he might
go to Baylor I'm always fascinated by
you know I know like it's cyclical in
nature you're going to be good bad but
like teams that stay down or that or
they drop off so hard well College
doesn't work like the draft right
because if you're the worst team so
Cleveland's the worst team they're yeah
they're unwatchable Browns are onat it's
crazy that they're zero and 13 or
something crazy they're so but they're
unwatchable it's crazy like you no one
they're never on TV so thank God but
they're going to get the first round
draft pick so hopefully in a couple
years like if they land a good
quarterback in the NFL quarterback's
everything if you get a good quarterback
offens line kind of set in college if
you had a shitty school no one's ever
going to commit there yeah because if a
good player he can go to these top 25
teams so it's like when you're [__]
you're just [__] you think makes sense
that you give the worst team the first
draft pick because aren't you kind of
rewarding shitty well there's there's
been that argument I mean there's been
that argument in because then you have
world all star is in a shitty team and
they kind of disappear when there's Hot
Prospects like big time gener like once
in a generation prospects there will be
the talk of like are are the [__] teams
throwing this game to stay shittier in
other words like really bad basketball
teams
they know um you know like Simmons BJ
Simmons they'll go uh I want this guy
NFL same way they'll be like there's a
hot hot and like especially quarterback
prospects quarterbacks only really come
once every like legit like once every
five six years depend godamn it'll be
late late [__] season regular season
and sometimes they'll be starters out of
the game and you're like what starters
being rested for and they're like
they're like well [__] you know
trying to get that trying to get that
come up son makes sense I was at when I
was in Phoenix this weekend at the Hotel
Palomar the saints were staying there
and I figured it out cuz I was walk
around I would see these giant dudes in
the elevator and I was like well you
don't look like a normal human being
what's going on here then I found out I
go are you guys in town I just said what
you play who Do you play with Saints you
know I'm talking to him I came out when
they were on their way to the game that
Sunday yeah uh well they it may as well
been the president they got these buses
with the security with the sheriffs I
mean they got had five different five
different SUVs of of police officers
dude you know I they think somebody's
going to [__] with them I got to drive
in a police escort one time and it was
one of those things where it's still one
of the Thrills of life for what game so
my buddy's dad was the head coach at
North Carolina sick so tar Hills yeah
and they were playing the Hurricanes so
we I flew down to Miami how long goes
this this was probably six seven years
ago flew down to Miami and the night is
the night before and where we see is Dad
we have dinner with him we just hanging
it's his dad you know so we're having
dinner talking all kinds of stuff oh we
talk about the game all right we you
know we'll see you in the morning so
next morning we go down and it's like
for a second it's almost like you forget
the level of you know caliber programs
these are so he's like hey Dad like how
do we go to the game and his dad looks
around because there's the team buses
and there's um there's Florida highway
patrolman motorcycles all these car
they're about to ES
from the hotel to the Orange Bowl this
is when the Orange Bowl was still there
yeah and uh terrible St and he goes uh
he he talks to one of the the cops he
goes it's my son uh can they and the guy
goes just drive behind the bus cuz I
have a car and I'm like okay and I'm
forgetting what speed we're going to do
this at because there's buses I figured
we're going to go like just Cruise dude
these buses are doing a 100 God down 95
and I keep falling behind a little bit
because I also don't want to run into
the bus so I'm Yeah man so I'm like I
would like dip out to you know 85 and
the cop behind me would be like damn
like go go go so we're sitting there
just flying and they closed it's it's
like a a presidential you know motorc
yeah then as we pull off and we're
pulling into the Orange Bowl this local
cop who had cut stopped local traffic
sees me in the motorcade and he goes you
[__] there cuz he thinks that I
jumped in on this mhm and then I I watch
another cop go like no no he's with us
and then we just pull into the Orange
Bowl and I'm like holy [__] like I I
mean it was like orange ball yeah and
it's also like I feel like I was just in
a race like a legal race God and then we
just they just the the team bus goes
down this tunnel and then they're like
oh just park wherever and we're like
okay just leave it here yeah we just
pull in I'm like I just got to go with
an escort yeah 100 miles an hour down
did North Carolina get their ass whooped
no but it was actually [__] I mean you
know cuz I'm with my my friend uh I
remember right before the half the uh
slot receiver dropped over North
Carolina yeah touchdown in the end zone
he dropped it right through his hand
this is six years ago yeah and then they
ended up losing but they lost a close
game it was [__] up Miami for a while
I mean they're getting a little better
now but for a while they kind of sucked
yeah they've had a down they've had a
down a longer downtrend than I'm like
that's what I'm talking about also like
if you can recruit Miami you know like
if you can pull players out of there and
they'll pull four and five star guys but
they just won't come together that might
be the coaching there like I feel like
college is more coaching just to your
point with college basketball like it's
so much more important for the game plan
and the schemes in college because they
have again you can say hey if you if you
don't show up at this time you're you're
off what happened to another Dame this
year they're so bad I know they're so
bad doesn't make sense how can you be
that bad
has to be coaching yeah or injuries
quarterbacks yeah injuries sometimes but
at Notre Dame I say at Florida State too
like there's an All-American third
string All-American just waiting to get
a shot at some of those schools I
remember that in the the late 90s um
meeting a couple guys that played at FSU
who they were like all first team All
State you know second team allamerican
like best athlete in their County and
they're like I got a little scrub time
what SP what what did you play besides
boxing and dance I danced I did uh choir
and then football and basketball two
sports I like stuff I like I'll tell you
what's crazy too is even at like Ohio
State fla Ohio State Florida State's a
little different even at CU When I was
there we had an NFL scout come in this
was before the combine pro day yeah and
he goes gentlemen how many want to go to
the NFL raise your
hand everybody ra your hand he goes
there might be two of you and who makes
it damn sounds like comy and acting we
all yeah all right we had um a guy who
went to the other High School who who
had played in the NFL six seven years as
a receiver he played at Miami come to
our high school once right cuz I went to
high school in Florida and he was like
you know he was like you guys need to
step up like all you guys are [__]
right and we were like I don't know I
think we were like ranked at time we're
like we're pretty good right he was like
I mean y'all ain't [__] and he was like
let me show you how much [__] F
faster I am than all of you and oh Jesus
so he was like uh he got there was a kid
on our team who won the 100 meters in
Florida so he's a legit fast
kid this guy was probably yeah he was
not not his name was jron so yeah jron
jron jron jron they call him jron jron
call him jron Jay lightning Jay Jay was
quick uh this dude got five yards ahead
of him no five yards behind him oh and
was like Let's Race and we're like yo
Jay's going to light this dude up
because he's the fastest guy we've ever
seen for sure and this guy might be uh
might be quick but you can't give him a
five yard Head Start it was like a
[__] cheah dude it was like I've
never seen anything like it and he knew
he just knew he [__] knew like the
fast what he knew is he knew he was
faster than any High School Sprinter in
the world that's what he he he did he
also did a thing where when he ran pass
him he also turned around you know like
and he was yeah he clowned him dude
there's certain times I I feel like in
sports especially when we played at
University of Miami at the orange ball
yeah I remember cuz growing up it's
Miami man I mean it was they had
everybody like they were so good and
we're there I'm like God I can't believe
I'm playing here I'm like they're really
not that much different than us helmet
shoulder bads BL we they look the same
way more black guys but they look the
same and then I'm sitting there I'm like
yeah think this college football thing
is not you know everyone's the same blah
blah blah and then they throw a ball
where uh I mean Spider-Man can catch it
we it was it was sonoris Moss Anana
Moss's he and he jumped in the air and I
was
like and he caught like oh my God and
they ran I was like yeah they're not the
same oh no there's just certain times
where you're just like oh it's just
that's Li did you watch uh that 30 for
30 Catholics versus convi it's so good I
love those 30 for 30 I didn't see the
Catholics versus it's so [__] good
man they're so well done yeah it really
it's like it's it's such a good story
too if you w it's you know that that I
remember those games you know that's
that's the era that I got into college
the comics were Miami right yeah and it
was like this whole thing so many they
were like bad boys my father still has
yeah my brother-in-law is a huge
University of Miami fan and my dad and
he'll watch it my father actively Ro
against Miami my father is doesn't like
Miami cuz he calls them the convicts and
and my brother-in-law loves Miami
this [__] weird rivalry where my
dad's like the comics and my
brother-in-law like give him a chance
man they that was a long time ago no
they they need the convic that's why
they're not very good cuz they got away
from it you Colorado did the same thing
too I was telling Brian that we had a
current event where one of the lead
receivers whatever punch some dude in
the face of the bar I'm like we ready
yeah we ready to go go ahead and arrest
him give him a little give him a little
pen time you know what I'm saying I was
watching that with my dad actually that
that thir and he was reminding me of a
few years ago this article about
University of Miami player um had shots
fired at him and then in the next line
it says and then the player returned
fire so so because like dude and you
know carry guns college football's in a
weird space and I was arguing with the
Twitter people this morning so uh
Christian McCaffrey right yeah he go he
plays for Stanford his his dad's Ed
mcaffry ridiculous player white running
back MH hash white running backs matter
so he [__] Heisman hopeful two years
in a row rushed for 2,000 years last
year 1500 yard freak just a freak yeah
he is and the Stanford hasn't had a
great year they've had a Dan year
they're in the sunball and now he has a
chance to go to the NFL and he goes I'm
out man I'm you know I'm not playing in
this I'm GNA get ready for the NFL he's
getting so much [__] people like you owe
it to the university what about your
teammates and my aru and it should be
anyone's argument you know how much
money they've made off jersey sales the
bowl game they went to last year the
games that he's won they they should not
only pay for his education but should be
paying him millions of dollars that's
what they don't understand I mean I
think that playing in a bowl game is
definitely up to the player uh I I
wouldn't critique a guy for being like
you know what I took it this far I want
to have my knees um just by chance if
something were to happen I mean you know
good on you if you want to play but that
that guy not playing in that doesn't
bother me people are so upset but but
he's also a running back
yeah a lineman he takes back punts too
he takes back chances of getting hurt
are way higher obviously for him it's
high also running back's careers are
shorter than any ones yeah so he's
looking at going and now if it was the
playoff series like if he was on Ohio
State he's like I'm not playing that's a
little different animal cuz you're up
for a national championship definitely
different animal sunb sunbow come on the
[__] if it was up the street I would to
go watch did you tell me that like most
running backs NFL fruit and I like
flowers and if this bow ain't got one of
them I ain't
playing did someone say
that I like cuz they're talking about
the the [__] orange ball the Rose
Ball sugar fruit like FL
yeah I ain't playing Leon Washington
said that oh really Florida state fruit
I like flowers that's hilarious I ain't
playing no [__] Foot Locker
ball he's right yeah he he was right for
sure the other bows are [__] yeah
you can be five and seven it's like
we're talking about six so six games and
like you're in bowl and how many games
in the college
season uh what is it 12 now yeah cuz
teams are what 111 you you tell me that
the in the NFL it's very rare to see a
running back over the age of 30 F yeah
it is hell yeah oh yeah then you see
these guys who play like 10 plus years
uh what was his name Miami guy uh Frank
Gore remember how long Gore M those
guy's a long time to run the ball Bettis
ran long time going back Chris mcav I
think he's seing Reverse Racism really I
do because if he was a black running
back and was putting up the type of
numbers he was doing yeah I don't feel
like he'd be getting as much [__] for
sticking out of the B but F the B but
but also just notoriety like he's a
freak man but he's a privileged white
kid his dad's a superstar comes for
money he just Happ to be this freak
football player but he's a white running
back you don't see a lot of media
coverage on him you really don't you
mean on on this actual choice or just in
general you don't see in general really
yeah I think it's reverse I would I
would think because he's such an outlier
that you'd get a lot of media no because
he's not he's really not and to win the
Heisman you need that coverage yeah he
didn't have a Heisman year this year but
last year he could have won it for sure
he he came he came close right was
second or third I think yeah yeah I
don't know man also white running back
tough gig is he the only running have
there's no I don't think well there's
there's no stars aside him there there
was Hillis and then there I think
homeboy that played at uh Stamford who
was with the Vikings for a little bit
who finished like fifth in Heisman
voting yeah there's not a lot though
white running back there's a reason why
there's bias towards him sure yeah what
play what position let's see um there's
a there's a handful of white receivers
um no white cornerbacks
that's what you don't see a lot of for
sure shout out Jason seahorn that's guy
to do the D thing you remember that
remember when he got shut down by
Terrell Owens in that game I remember
watching that and Terell Owens was like
I'm gonna just go out here I'm gonna I'm
just gonna cut left and catch the ball
in your face and Jason C is amazing
athlete made some incredible
interceptions and Terrell Owens just
that's the first time I started watching
a lot of football and I saw this guy in
the 49ers I didn't really know he was
Terrell Owens but I was watching him I
was like this guy is [__] catching
the ball at will he's just going White
Corner no no not a lot receiver they're
only slot like Speedy guys they're not
the big guys they're only like I can
think of one like the westers then you
got the boy Nelson Jordy Nelson you got
homeboy for uh the Cowboys who's the
slot receiver but usually the the slot
like Wayne cre super oldo I know that
was the last time he got such a bad he
had like five concussions and had I
guess I guess o line and quarterback
really for white guys yeah there's and
then like you see a couple obviously
ends you know JJ Jared Allen tackle not
that many not that many there's a book
on this linebackers the ones that stick
out the white guys are really good like
sha Lee uh kley for uh Carolina this guy
wait wait for Owens you got to look this
up on YouTube look up sea Taylor Terell
Owens yeah and there's a highlight reel
of Taylor just
[__] absolutely just bullying him for
a whole game wow and like running him
out of bounds [__] throwing his
helmet and like you see Owens cower
through this video it's unbelievable so
it's trell and Shan Taylor Sean Taylor's
dead now but he got he got shot his
house hit him in the leg leg Yeah and he
BL out remember that he [__] bullies
him and you're like might been one the
biggest freaks in the Nfl safety wise is
huge huge and [__] nasty nasty and
then and this dude ter who talked most
[__] is like head down really just broke
them you you see it he breaks them it's
it's unbelievable there men out there
that can break you yeah there are men
out there that can impose their will I
believe that's one of the most important
aspects and lessons of sport yeah it
teaches you where your place is teaches
you how tough you're not teaches you how
tough you are also teaches you how tough
you're not yeah and I think that's a
very important thing it's kind of what
the military does when mandatory drafts
count have mandatory drafts you can't
really come out of two three four of the
military a lot of times it be a complete
smart ass it'll knock some of the smart
the Marines it'll knock some of the
smart ass out it's also that lesson you
learn like if people like boys
especially who don't play sports any
sports cocky they don't they don't like
they're like uh you ever play like yeah
you if you've never had like your ass
kicked punch in the face like it's
different yeah exactly punch in the face
or have someone throw you um you know
just [__] body check you and you're
like holy [__] like this dude's so much
[__] yeah you know what happens to you
get quiet yeah you do you get quiet and
you mull it over you're like hey hold on
there are dud but if you don't play
sports when would you ever get checked
like that like if you're big businessman
you know what I'm saying like there's
there's certain guys but money same
thing with money same real rich people
I'm like my fa like you see that a lot
here too like do think they have money
like you know it's like they're like I
got I got $100,000 and like you know
they think they're wealthy that was
Donald Trump who said mitt Romy doesn't
have isn't Rich I'm rich yeah exactly
but you know there's a those they never
get checked sometimes yeah they they
don't get checked for a long time until
someone like that comes around right I
mean well but even then you think you're
rich I have4 billion dollar he's like
all right I'm still Rich As [__] like
that's a good point but I I go home to
my 18 crib you know what I'm saying like
I live in belir I got all these whips
man yeah I got all these whips like I
get it you're rich my father told me a
crazy story about one this insanely
wealthy guy and there was this Texan and
he had like you know $300 million and
the guy was just he was around these
real real you know there's rich and then
we were talking there's the then they're
the quiet [__] right for sure
and my father knew this one guy who's
just got more money than you know he's
one of the top 10 richest people in the
world and quiet and there was a Texan
and they were playing uh Texas holdom or
some [__] some game and they're all
playing in a friendly game when they're
that rich They're all playing for like
you know $100 a year and this Texan kept
talking about the stuff he has much
money he has how he play Slots for
$100,000 whatever and my father said the
guy said um he he basically said he had
a t he goes and Tex and said get ready
to antie up boys what I being ass and
the guy got had had enough and he said
what are you worth and the guy said $300
million something like that and he goes
I'll bet you all of
it and there was a
pause and everybody at the table
realized that this guy was dead serious
yeah and that he could bet something
crazy
yeah and that Texon didn't say another
[__] word cuz don't [__] look there's
a pecking order and there are people
that can actually I'd be like all right
so you have 300 jillion I have 300
million everything's still free man like
what I don't know what else to do with
my money the context of the get being
like yeah punk I get itut fcking but
even then they really don't get checked
like sometimes like uh my girl loves
Rodeo Drive we're at Rodeo Drive and
we're in uh Gucci and we're around and
there's a dude dude bumps into me he's
like this skinny Persian fell with more
clone on than I I I don't know what's
going on he bumped yeah way more than me
he has like scarves on it's hot as [__]
outside his glasses and he B he has
loafer gold loafers on he bumped in he
he has slaves he's he's a Chic 100% like
he's like that guy from 300 what's
what's his name the giant guy but he
tiners he's like a mini me of xeri but
he [__] he bumped in me but like rude
I don't care man I'm like oh damn excuse
me and he's like yeah I'm like oh no oh
no he said no let me see that nose ring
dou but it's like he lives in this world
where no one's ever like dude you can't
act like that show manners at least not
that I'd ever do anything I'm just like
dude he lives in this bubble where he
thinks like power you need to you need
to follow him in the bathroom when he's
at the UR all not a big deal please no
just grab him and squeeze him I'll watch
the door no no no no no I'll watch the
door look squeeze him really hard and
till he pooses pants yeah and then he'll
poo his pants and then you go Naughty
Boy you pooed your pants give me money
and then we wait till he comes out and
we go PE you what's that smell on this
[__] I don't know she she yeah
Sheik made a shitty she made a [__] she
made a shitty is in the corner going she
man [__] but that guy's never going to
there's going to be no reality check
because he's going to be the guy that
goes into the the club and orders bottle
service and that's kind of an ego thing
and then he jumps in his Royals Royce he
drives his house in Bell but there's
this bubble my experience though with
those guys that get older is that that
life checks them in other words they
just know that they're a fraud they just
know at the end of the day especially if
you're born a prince I think you have
might be AOL D you're going you're going
back on the on the on the on the guy now
maybe now the guy's cool well I'm you're
feeling bad about going bad on no I
didn't go bad on him well you squeezed
him and made him [__] his pants so I you
no you did I I was just watching the
door dude he might be a good guy but he
just does just doesn't live in the that
world you know yeah I guess it's good to
be ter so hard and I've got to go to the
set I got you do too yeah you to pee
hard oh you got to pee I'm gonna have to
run and go do standup I mean not standup
uh lying I have to go do Kingdom right
now we're doing standup tonight tonight
and I'm gonna come by I'll blasting it
out yeah you guys are gonna be at the
Laugh Factory tonight yeah you Harlem
Williams Jeremy Piven some big names
Chrysler yeah Russell uh hosting Brandon
Russell Peters Jeremy Piven uh Bert you
christalia that's I had a Dro Williams
can I do Marcus spear or spears AR
Spears yeah see Mark Spears was a
football player there you go AR Spears
though as a comedian before we go do you
mind if I just drop a little knowledge
for the hell of it I know it's out of
order just really quickly drop it I get
PE so bad though uh you know I always
give Eddie a hard time about conspiracy
theories and stuff and I'm not a big
cons iracy Theory guy but this is kind
of close to a conspiracy theory there's
an article in New York Times a prominent
medical journal on Monday published a
scathing attack on global Health advice
to eat less sugar warnings to eat sugar
the study agreed are based on weak
evidence and cannot be trusted here's
the
problem uh the review published in the
annals of internal medicine very very a
very sort of prestigious medicine thing
uh quickly elicited sharp criticism from
public health experts because the
authors have ties to the food and sugar
industries of course yeah the review is
paid for by the international Life
Sciences Institute really awesome name
the international Life Sciences
Institute a scientific group that is
based in Washington DC and is funded by
get this multinational food and
agrochemical companies like Coca-Cola
General Mills Hershey's Kelloggs craft
foods and monsano and one of the authors
is a member of the scientific Advisory
Board that's a very s scientific
sounding thing Tate and Lyall and guess
what they're one of the world's largest
suppliers of high fructose corn syrup
wow do you think there's a and they're
trying to get your kids to eat more
sugar and say that 25% of your diet can
be simple sugars care believe that the
she made it shitty Again The Sheiks got
you so there is where like in the
pharmaceutical companies do the same
thing they hijack the science cut sugar
bro so just be bra's right there it is
he's got some points what is he anti-
sugar nod Eddie thinks everything's a
conspiracy but I think that that could
be used as an example of of you know
that is a form have you ever had Eddie
on your show no never we don't have
guests we haven't had guests in two
years just doing the day you guys don't
need it just haven't done it yeah we'll
do it again Tom Soro we love you Bo
thank you for having me guys see you
tonight go to my site and uh toms.com I
have a big tour coming up I like starts
in January Instagram's Tom sigura yeah
at sigur Tom on Instagram seur Tom
backwards uh British kid took Tom godamn
it British kid he's 18 sweet kid you
want to secure your hips while you pee
be so bad let's go take our dicks out
yeah fun episode with Tom sigura Brian
had to get the set Tom had to I'm not
sure probably figure out some mommy
jeans or something like that but I will
see Tom tonight at the Laugh Factory for
the toy drive that starts at 10 pm uh
hopefully you guys enjoyed this one we
got a big brown breakdown tomorrow my
special guest Alan
joban and Pacific Northwest tour
Vancouver we had a date so we're there
the 18th the 19th 19th is sold out now
we're in Seattle Portland booya
tk.com for everything you need as far as
tour dates gear the sweatshirt I'm
wearing right now we restocked the fire
kid Army te so go get them thanks for
listening y'all this is the fireing the
kid we're out